morning all Argentina are on top of the
world this morning a thousand games into
his astonishing career Lionel Messi
lifted the famous trophy in qatar's
Lucille Stadium his teams well three old
draw over France went after the with the
one-on penalties of course it is being
hailed as one of the greatest World Cup
finals of all time Rob Harris now
reports from Doha
Argentina didn't wait to fly home to
start the parade
leaving Lucille Stadium on an open top
bus the World Cup was already on display
through the streets for qataris and
thousands of Argentine fans to join the
celebrations on the night Lionel Messi
fulfilled his destiny
Messi received the World Cup in Abyss
after being draped in the traditional
Arab cloak by the Emir of Qatar to close
this first World Cup in the Middle East
it's a final that began with a 35 year
old scoring the first against France
from the penalty spot Midway through the
first half
before his Majestic touch on the
counter-attack helped Angel Di Maria
double the lead
France reached 80 minutes without a shot
on target until a penalty finally
presented Killian mbappe with his chance
barely a minute was needed by mbappe to
complete an incredible turnaround at 2-2
the fingertips of hughal or east denied
Messi a late winner
but he did find a way to find the net
again in extra time
there was still another Twist from his
teammate at Qatar own Paris
Saint-Germain
and bappa's shot was handled The
Equalizer from the spot made him the
first man to score a World Cup final
hat-trick since the Jeff Hurst in 1966
3-3 ended penalties settled this
thrilling final
France missed two but Argentina starting
with Messi scored all theirs
a 4-2 shootout success celebrated across
Buenos Aires where Messi will soon be
joining the party
this F Ile and all
and all set will be remembered as
message final the night one of the
greatest footballers of all time won the
last major prize to elude him just like
Diego Maradona in 1986 Lionel Messi is a
World Cup winner with Argentina
confirming his legendary status we are
very very happy tonight this night is
wonderful
I was talking to my father he was crying
I was crying until five ten minutes ago
I can't believe it I still can't believe
it
it's very special for the
for the people Argentina
for the people like the foodwork for me
for my family this world cup will
forever be shrouded in controversy for
the discrimination and deaths of Migrant
workers but the most expensive sports
event ever staged gave Qatar its dream
final
for Messi this is where he finally
conquered the world as one of football's
ultimate winners Rob Harris Sky News
LaSalle in Qatar
I know it was Argentina's first World
Cup win since 1986 when it was Diego
Maradona lifting the trophy in Mexico
hundreds of thousands of people poured
onto the streets of Buenos Aires to
celebrate after a roller coaster of
emotions
and this was the scene at maradona's
home he'll no doubt be looking down with
a smile on his face Freya channel has
more from Buenos Aires
look at this
[Applause]
team has won his past ever
done it look how happy people are here
today I mean that was a really really
tense moment just then everyone was
silence
reliably informed that Freya is actually
absolutely fine um but let's move our
attention away from the football to the
strikes and remind you which ones are
happening this week well there will be
four more rail walkouts uh this time
four days around Christmas but also in
January as well at members of the Royal
College of Nursing in England Wales and
Northern Ireland they'll be walking out
for a second time on Tuesday
what about ambulance staff well that
includes paramedics Emergency Care
assistants and call handlers they aren't
due to strike on the 21st and the 28th
meanwhile postal workers will stage
another two-day strike from the 23rd
Board of force is to be walking away
from the job or from the 23rd to the
26th and then again from the 28th to the
31st
and from today driving test examiners
and some civil servants will also join
the ruling strike action
I would like to speak this guy's
Katarina batazi who is in Liverpool for
us today and and any number of people
striking today but including uh civil
servants
yes we're outside a job center plus here
in Liverpool where members of the pcsu
units of public and Commercial Services
Union uh particularly this uh one the
department of work and pensions amongst
many public sector and civil servants
service agencies as you say striking
today about
30 40 people here on the picket line
let's speak to Martin Kavanagh who's
been organizing this but a number of
civil service civil sector strikes today
tell us
what are you asking for okay well I mean
our members have experienced 20 years
and more of paid restraints under the
government's of the various governments
and right now our offer I've been
imposed Upon Our members right across
the Civil Service it's now rid of the
two percent were inflation's running 11
so the cost of living crisis is biting
really hard job security has rapidly
becoming a thing of the past in the
Silver Service
the government are intending to cut our
redundancy terms by a third and in
addition to that our members have since
2019 overpaid every single month two
percent more for their pensions than the
government's own
calculations suggest we should so it's a
real terms pay cut on top of what we're
already suffering have you had any
counter offers any movement from the
government about what your demands what
you're asking for absolutely nothing no
I mean we've written to the government
as soon as we got the live Monday
through early in November we wrote to
the government the governments have said
the door is open and that if the door is
not closed the talks but there's not
been one single penny offered there's
not even an offer of more potentially
more money if we get back around the
negotiating table so our members right
across various sectors of the Civil
Service since last week are being taken
action to try and get the government to
move our members desperately money now
that is a phrase we've heard and our
viewers will have heard the door is
always open on the side of the women
what does that actually mean for people
negotiating from your side is there a
sense that there is an open
communication flow to try and prevent
strikes like this at a time of year when
you know there are people who will be
worried now that they won't be able to
get the correct benefits in time for
Christmas because of actions like this I
mean we are prepared to talk at any time
we've always been very clear about that
our general secretary Mark sawaka has
been very clear about that but there's
no point being open for talks if the
government are prepared to at least
start the process of trying to talk
about more money now there's no good
offering Jam tomorrow and then the
government's case not even offering Jam
tomorrow they're expecting their own
Workforce at a time of the economic
crisis to basically have a 10 real
estate costs when families are going on
there when we know that the services are
desperately needed Across The Wider
communities and our members are not just
facing that pay course and not the
harshest Christmas and winter they've
ever faced but actually the service they
provided are going under because at the
same time the threat to job costs
thousands of job costs is hanging over
our members constantly but the time
working pensions have said based on the
calculations of your offer is
unaffordable that the pay increases that
you're asking for in the costing it
about you know over two billion pounds
they say we simply can't afford that at
the moment what'd you say about that we
just got Bala we do not buy that at all
we know that billions of pounds the
public payers are squandered month in
month hours we understand the no because
we see the headlines that only a
fortnight ago the government was
prepared to write off billions of pounds
in unused air contracts that didn't
appear or materialize you on a pandemic
their own Workforce now has our 20 years
of pay restraints the government has to
ask the responsibility to actually come
to us and say we want to open up
negotiations we are serious about giving
you more money because we understand the
next steps that it's wrong the civil
servants who provide benefit have to go
around the other side of the counter and
claim benefit forty thousand of our
members haven't do that 45 000 are used
in food banks Melissa Kevin thank you
very much organizing today's protests
here in Liverpool One of similar sites
across England today public and
Commercial Services Union Civil sector
workers across a variety of different
agencies on strike pay the key demand
Katarina thank you
let's stick with the strikes focusing
this time on on what's going on within
the Health Service joining us our
political correspondent at Tamara Cohen
and tomorrow we I keep hearing this
Mantra that we want to keep negotiations
going Steve Barkley reaching out to the
unions to see if they can secure more
talks but again I asked a very simple
straightforward question if they are not
going to talk about pay which is why the
nurses are on strike what on Earth is
the point
well that message about no negotiation
on pay is made again loud and clear this
morning Steve Barkley has said he wants
to talk to the unions of course we've
got the nurses going on strike again
tomorrow and ambulance trusts five of
them in England going on strike on
Wednesday for the first time in 30 years
both of the the unions representing them
have said they want substantive talks
about pay but the message from a source
at the Department of Health this morning
is that the position on pay hasn't
changed and what Steve Barkley is Keen
to talk to them about is patient safety
and non-pay issues that both of the
unions have also raised so the prospect
of any of the strikes this week being
called off looks pretty remote at the
moment as to whether there is much
clamor politically for the government to
secure a deal perhaps by giving a
one-off pay rise to the nurses as has
been suggested I'm not detecting much
clamor from Tory MPS to be honest
yesterday a cabinet minister said the
government was resolute shoot on no
negotiations and it seems that that
position stands this morning
thanks Tamara
a huge rescue operation is underway in
the Gulf of Thailand to rescue missing
Sailors from a sinking warship the Thai
military has sent three Navy vessels and
two helicopters after the warships
suffered an engine malfunction amidst
choppy Waters
well the ship itself went down before
midnight just south of Bangkok more than
30 Sailors are still missing
the high court will hand out its
judgment on a legal challenge to the
government's controversial Rwanda
deportation policy later today the first
planned deportational flight was blocked
in June by last minute injunction then
campaigners brought a judicial review
ministers have said the policy is
necessary to deter illegal immigration
they also insist Rwanda is a safe
country for people to be sent to
steel workers will be marching to 10
Downing Street this afternoon to deliver
a petition to the Prime Minister which
says the government must step up to
protect the steel industry
bus fares have been capped at two pounds
by 130 operators outside London to help
passengers with the cost of living
crisis children's tickets will be Frozen
at one pound the department for
transport is funding the 60 million
pound scheme in England
uh well there are growing concerns about
anti-jewish hate crime and the
government's independent advisor is
calling on secondary schools to cover
contemporary anti-Semitism in addition
to learning about the Holocaust and we
are joined now on the program by that
advisor Lord man Lord man very good
morning to you good morning
um explain the rationale behind this is
that I would have thought particularly
given that the anti-Semitism that has
been that has been in the political
process over the past few years that
this would be something that would
already be taught in schools just just
explain that why why at what level it is
at the moment if at all and why you feel
that the Contemporary anti-Semitism
needs to be taught well Holocaust
Education is taught in schools but
contemporary anti-Semitism so what uh
young Jewish teenagers suffer on the
streets or in school or elsewhere on
social media it isn't covered in schools
at all and I'm suggesting a very simple
change that it should be inserted in a
very small way into the school
curriculum in secondary schools and
perhaps even more significantly that
teaches as part of their teacher
training and their professional
development should have again a small
but vitally important element of
learning what is anti-Semitism and how
to deal with it and the basis for saying
that is the research that I've seen but
also that I've carried out not least
from The Institute of Education who do
most of the teacher training in how to
teach the Holocaust they say to me
they're repeatedly asked about
contemporary anti-Semitism how to deal
with issues in schools and it's clear
that teachers don't have sufficient
knowledge or anti-Semitism is and
haven't been taught in the skills of how
to deal with it a small input could have
a disproportionate impact so I'm
recommending that to government but
beyond that we've actually begun the
work of how that's done
with one Academy chain the outward
Grange Academy trick chain in the north
of England and the national Holocaust
Center and The Institute of Education
are part of the team of experts who are
taking that forward over the next year
so we're providing something for
government that should be ready by the
end of the year I'm sent to government
we need something in every school not
just in this one particular chain of
schools indeed and I can I can
completely see the rationale for that I
just wonder what has been the driver of
this this rise in anti-Semitism directed
towards but and indeed can you know have
been shared amongst young people I mean
people do think of immediately will go
to people at Kanye West and the
important comments that that he made but
there is a rather more Insidious element
to this and it's the the involvement of
Neo-Nazi groups there is the the the far
right is uh not so much resurgent but is
using the internet to good impact to
spread its hatred you know where does
West get his quite bizarre but
consistent thread of hatred from you
know how does that get into his head
well uh I don't know but I do know it
has to be challenged and educated about
and whenever there's conflict in the
Middle East we see a spike in
anti-semitic incidents
and that means abuse violence threats
directed particularly against Jewish
teenagers beat on the bus at the bus
stop in schools or elsewhere and so this
needs to be better challenged education
complaints part and it's the one I've
looked back over the last 15 years over
what we've done
in some places a very good job's been
done the situation in universities has
been turned round but schools have been
ignored that now has to be a top
priority and I'm recommending that today
to government
I will let's see what the government
come back with there John man Lord man
lovely to have you on the program and
have a very Merry Christmas when it
comes thank you
uh no let's have a quick look at the
weather and you might have noticed
there's been a bit of a big swing in
temperatures from freezing to thawing uh
Skies meteorologist Joe Robinson is no
longer shivering in her back Garden in
Oxfordshire this morning in fact it
looks not too bad is this going to last
though Joe
well the very mild conditions that we're
seeing today that will last for today it
will be mild or temperatures around
average for the next few days and then
there are signs that we will see that
Arctic air trying to move in again as we
head towards Christmas at the moment
there's some uncertainty but it's
looking like northern areas could see
that Arctic care moving in and a risk of
some snow as we head towards Christmas
day but that moderate more likely in the
South but the 730 so that's something
that we can keep an eye on but certainly
for today highs of around 14 or 15
degrees Celsius so a big change from
last week
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
so we've lost our Arctic air now we have
temperatures already at 13 or 14 degrees
Celsius quite widely there are some
warnings though we do have that very
mild air but it does mean that we have
got some heavy rain and strong winds so
some heavy rain across Southern Parts
particularly today there are warnings in
place by the Met Office in excess of 100
millimeters is possible on Dartmoor so
warnings in place but a very mild day
outbreaks of rain spreading eastwards
across many areas and strong winds too
with Coastal Gales in places further
rain tonight but drier on Tuesday let's
bring you a little more on the World Cup
to borrow a phrase 30 years of hurt 36
of them in fact ended for Argentina with
that victory over France and Buenos
Aires went Bonkers hundreds of thousands
of people poured onto the streets into
the fountains up the poles and they
parted into the night our let's get some
reaction from Argentina and speak to one
fan Paola brachi Paola first and
foremost congrats relations have you
been to bed yet
thank you very much thank you very much
um I I
live in the capital city but here the
the celebrations have been crazy too I I
couldn't get to the to the Obelisk but
here people are crazy are very very
happy euphoric about things they've been
waiting for this for a long time so we
are we are really really really excited
about the results where are you
confident going into the match because
France to be fair they were looking
pretty good
yeah they were in fact I think that I'm
not a football like specialist but I
thought that they played really well too
um but yeah I was confident I was really
confident because this team is
um I really liked the team uh everyone
uh who was in the team and they when
they were young you know they they had
Messi as an idol and they they grew up
um looking up to him and and the fact
that they were playing together now I
think this has made it I don't know more
more exciting it has made their dream
come true they they were really into the
game they were really into what they
they had to do for what the people here
were expecting and and this is what they
did so so what do you think what next
for Lionel Messi I mean is this the
point that he hangs up the boots and
heads off into the sunset or or do you
think is some are suggesting he could be
there in four years time when Argentina
defend the title
for
um I mean he he could be still part of
the Argentinian football in in other I
don't know in in another part like not
as a player I don't think I think he was
waiting for this he had been waiting for
this for a very long time and this is it
this is like the highest point uh and I
don't think there will be another match
as exciting as this one another world
cup another final as exciting as this
one so I think this is uh This Is It
that that will be it's for him do you
know what um well I agree certainly
agree with you as to the quality of the
final but I'll keep my fingers crossed
we might just see a little bit more of
Lionel Messi and Paola brachi thank you
so much for joining us congratulations
and have a lovely Christmas when it
comes an inquest is opening this morning
into the deaths of four young boys aged
between 6 and 11 who fell into a frozen
lake in solihull in the West Midlands
Oliver Bennett is in Birmingham Forest
this morning good to see you either I
suspect that this is just very much the
early stages the opening of the inquest
itself it will probably run for some
time
uh the opening and also the adjournment
already
um Neil Nile because uh it was decided
uh the coroner said Mrs Louise hunt that
um uh he really only opened it to say
that it's been decided that no
post-mortems will be carried out because
they're the boy's death clearly relate
to Drowning she said Samuel Butler was
the youngest victim of this tragic
incident he was just six years old he
died alongside his brother Finley Butler
um their cousin Thomas Stewart who was
11 years old and uh their friend Jack
Johnson who was 10 they died last Sunday
at babsmill Lake and solihull after
falling through the ice at the beginning
of that cold period of weather they were
rescued from the Frozen water and rushed
to hospital but that's where they were
pronounced dead
and it was announced that they died
after suffering Cardiac Arrest but now
we know that their deaths clearly relate
to Drowning according to the coroner
here last night of course we saw
hundreds turn out for a vigil at the
lake in their memory a lot of people in
tears there too after a clear a very
emotional impact on the community there
the coroner did also say that a full
inquest its hope will help the families
of these little boys understand exactly
what happened to them and the Valiant
efforts by the emergency services to try
to save them as I say the inquest has
now been adjourned until the summer
I have a thank you
well it is of course the run into
Christmas so let's talk about people
providing some kindness this Christmas
statistics have shown that over 50
percent of Supermarket Shoppers are
donating to food collections all part of
an attempt to support those hardest hit
by the cost of living now these
donations help food banks across the
country provide emergency food Parcels
to those in crisis our reporter sadio is
a truffle trust food bank in Hackney in
East London followers this morning Sadia
good to see you over 50 percent of
Supermarket Shoppers donating to food
collections that is quite something
yes and we're at one of these warehouses
where some of that food comes in so all
of this food here has been donated by
Tesco customers who have donated 12.5
million meals already this year and
during a three-day Drive earlier this
month they donated at 2.4 million meals
but it is needed it's a huge amount but
it is needed because the trustful trust
Network says that they are giving out
food Parcels every 13 seconds that's
quite an incredible number we can go
over now and talk to Pat Fitzsimmons who
is from the Trussell trust Network thank
you very much for speaking to us Pat it
is never a good thing when food banks do
so well in this in this sense is it well
most Charities don't want to exist but
really food banks do not want to exist
the Trussell trust does not want to
exist it's a symptom of a broken system
and we don't want to be propping it up
but we have no option and what kind of
things are people donating and what is
needed you've got a pack here you're
just going to talk through some of the
items well we have a list that has been
developed between the Trussell trust and
the NHS to have a three-day pack that is
nutrition nutritionally balanced a few
of the items that we really need all the
time
are these we need tin fruit we need
corned beef it's not something that
people would think of immediately so
it's important that people know the
sorts of things that we really need all
year round
Christmas there's a particular time that
we see a lot of generosity but are we
reaching everyone or does do we need to
see this kind of donation go through all
the way into January as well oh
definitely definitely definitely we are
not seeing everyone we know that people
don't know about food banks the people
who really need it don't know about it
so yes we get a lot of donations at
Christmas we really need it all year
round because demand is rising and
rising and Rising which is not good
excellent Pat thank you so much for
speaking to us well Tesco says that it
has food collection points in every
single one of its stores now which it
says helps its customers make sure that
other people get some of that food as
well
Sadia thank you
oh let's stick with this topic we'll
joined now by the CEO of food cycle Mary
McGrath and the founder of social bite
Josh littlejojohn both lovely to see you
um I wonder maybe if we can just start
with you just tell us a little bit about
about food cycle what it is you do and
the pressures that there are all new
currently because of the cost of living
crisis because of the cold
yeah Morning Neil um so food cycle
skills communities we provide A really
lovely three-course meal for people who
may be hungry or who are lonely and this
was that with the help of an amazing set
of volunteers up and down the country
we're up in Newcastle down in Exeter
over in Wales as well as London and the
southeast
um and we have really seen huge increase
in demand this year effectively we're
serving double the number of people uh
this time right now than we were at the
beginning of the year more people are in
need of a hearty warm meal and we're
delighted that we can provide that for
them
indeed um well let's bring in uh Josh uh
founder of socialbot and again kind of a
similar question to you I understand of
course yours is a movement to end
homelessness so on top of kind of the
cost of living crisis people going
hungry you know it's cold out there at
the moment and you know and there are
still hundreds of thousands of people
without adequate shelter just tell us a
little bit about social bite
yeah so social but it's a social
Enterprise and we've got a nationwide
chain of cafes where we offer jobs to
homeless people and we also run a Pay It
Forward system so customers in the cafes
you can basically buy something extra an
extra meal or an extra lunch or a hot
drink and homeless people are welcomed
in to get something for free that
someone's basically bought in advance
later and what this winter appeal will
enable is to for social bite to provide
tens of thousands of hot meals
um freshly made for people that are
homeless struggling like you say is
freezing conditions out there and so a
hot meal is something social important
and particularly as this cost of living
crisis takes great yeah it certainly
does and it's fantastic idea but back to
you Mary and if you want to have an idea
of just how how awful how concerning
things are are out there I'm told that
you met once well in Birmingham you met
a 64 year old there who is so concerned
about the cost of heating his home the
cost of electricity the cost and so on
that is no longer putting this cattle on
that's right yes we're getting stories
like that all the time and I've got a
fantastic team of people who are there
to help people who are unfortunately in
Desperate needs uh people who are going
hungry
um we we had a telephone call uh we've
had we're having several telephone calls
a day actually of people saying that
they're really really hungry they're
really cold and they're looking for
something to eat and I think the great
thing is we're able to provide that
support we look to find support for
people and actually giving people a warm
hot meal is really really important
um it many people are scared to put the
kettle on many people don't have ovens
um or afraid to turn on their ovens
there is a lot of discussion about
turning on the heat
um or or having warm food to eat and
when you have those choices it's great
that we have places like food cycle and
social bites for people to come to and
we're absolutely thrilled to be
supported as well by
um the just eat winter meal appeal where
you know people
um have been incredibly generous
actually
um they have donated the equivalent of
385
000 meals to this campaign which uh Josh
and I are absolutely thrilled with
that's fantastic absolutely fantastic
but I was just about to ask a question
on that I mean Josh look I I don't care
who you are I mean unless you're a
multi-millionaire you know all of us
have probably made changes to our life
you know as we run into Christmas
because of the cost of living crisis
everything's so much more expensive you
know my energy bills are going through
the roof does that mean even at a time
like this that you start to see perhaps
the the level of donation the level of
support that you get from the public
tapering away what going by what Mary
was saying not actually
well I mean you know I've been
um running social baiting over the last
10 years and it's always amazes me
um at times of Crisis and Society at
times of economic hardship you would
absolutely expect donations to taper in
but it's always in my experience so
inspiring to see that it's actually the
reverse and people sometimes without
very much and get you know give to those
that are even more in need and I think
they just eat was to Winter meal appeal
really demonstrates that I think I
understand they've had three times as
many people donating and the way it
works is when you go to the checkout and
you're ordering a takeaway and just eat
you can donate either a pound and five
pounds or ten pounds and this year
compared to last year they've had over
three times as many people than 18 and
Mary said that's helped to and fund to
that to this point
um over 385 000 hot meals which is going
to be delivered over Christmas and right
through winter and we're hoping that
those Nations keep going let them up to
the end of the year and hopefully we can
hit the half a million meal Target
do you know what it is the time of year
for giving thanks isn't it so you can
both have mine for all the work that you
do uh Mary McGrath see your food cycle
uh Josh Littlejohn founder of social
bike keep up the good work and have a
lovely Christmas when it comes you too
Niall thank you thank you thanks so much
Christmas songs well it can certainly
lift your spirits but for people living
with Parkinson's stroke or brain injury
Christmas music can do much more than
that helping them with communication
projection and even motor function
that's why songwriter Madeleine castry
has written an original Christmas song
sung entirely by those living and
affected by neurological disabilities
let's have a list
Christmas songs
[Music]
the songs writer and the founder of the
charity resonate Madeleine Cass Street
Madeleine great to see you this morning
I do hope you're well um just just tell
me a little bit about how this this song
came about obviously you have you have
written it but performance duties have
been handed over
well this project was fundamentally born
out of my belief that music really can
change lives and over after overcoming
illness myself as a teenager I began to
fundraise and I was using my musical
background to Stage little local
concerts and that all began over 10
years ago and this then coincided with
me meeting a wonderful lady living with
Parkinson's and she was a huge huge
lover of singing so I began to think
about how the classical singing
technique I was trained with could be
made a little bit more accessible to
help her live with her condition and
this snowballed into working with
broader Parkinson's support groups and
now some wonderful groups made up of
those living with the effects of stroke
and brain injury and this song is the
result it really is a shared effort to
show that music really really can change
lives I mean what is fascinating to me
and I've done I know I think or two
about Parkinson's what fascinates me is
of course getting together and singing
everyone understands the benefits of
something that that raises the spirit
you make friends you have a laugh but
the idea that singing like this can
bring people together and actually have
you know an effect on on motor skills of
course one of the one of the problems
with Parkinson's is that degrading kind
of motor skill that you have that is
that is fascinating to me tell me a
little bit more
well whenever I approached a project
like this I'm always mindful of the
different symptoms that can present
themselves so for instance Parkinson's
has over 40 different symptoms and a lot
of people just think of Parkinson's as
the shake but actually it isn't there's
so many many different symptoms and of
course stroke is different for every
person but one thing that you might not
consider is how this can affect the
voice so breathing perception of volume
Clarity of words these are all impacted
by neurological disease and the voices
obviously our main method of
communication so it must be so isolating
when that is compromised by a
neurological disability so the songs
that I write are made up of motifs that
assist in phonation I've considered
things like breath support can you can
you just explain that sorry for it's
very early on a Monday morning you'll
have to explain the terminology
Phoenician what do you mean there the
nation so it's basically how you form
your words and obviously when you lose
the ability to access certain muscles as
easily particularly in the cases of
stroke it's very important that we
engage to what we call the articulators
so things that move in the mouth and
these can be starting with very small
exercises like imagining you're chewing
a toffee and it's getting bigger in your
mouth and but then obviously you put
this into phrase and I think that
sometimes one of the real big stumbling
blocks with neurological conditions is
that spontaneity that we have in speech
but we don't necessarily get that with
music because we have the beats and the
Rhythm to help us so what I've tried to
do with these songs is create little
phrases and they're not just uplifting
messages of Hope which I hope that
everybody can resonate with but they're
also little pocket motifs that people
can use when maybe they freeze or they
stumble over their words to get their
articulators to get their face moving
and really really help them improve
their quality of life and of course it
strikes me you know you're classically
trained yourselves I mean the one thing
the classically trained singers never
have to worry about is their posture
posture of course and another issue for
a number of those kind of neurological
conditions just wondering though of the
people that you have been interacting
with and in producing this single what
have they been saying to you I mean I
was looking at the video there and
everyone seems to be having a ball
well I don't necessarily think that they
realize the effect that music can have
on them so it really really is a case
where I've been working with people and
their partners and spouses have come up
to me and said this is the first time
they've spoken coherently in years
because all of a sudden they've got
access to this breath support that they
weren't necessarily using before and
also sometimes something so you know we
wouldn't necessarily think it has such
power but speaking to a beat using a
familiar Soul or even a little made-up
Rhythm to articulate that speech and to
give you that kind of signposting
through a phrase it just gives you that
new sense of coherency and I think above
all else there's nothing more powerful
than giving the gift of voice and
communication particularly at Christmas
and these wonderful courageous people
have been you know they've been
effectively silenced by these
neurological conditions and such cruel
diseases and to be able to get them to
communicate again through music well
that's totally Priceless Madeline we are
almost out of time in the program but so
tell us where can we get hold of the
single uh well the single is available
on all streaming platforms and if you
want to have a look at the charity
website which is
resonatemusic.org.uk there's lots of
support materials on there to get
everybody involved in using music and
singing for health and wellness and
those living with disability and those
who just want to use music to spread all
on their website
um Madeline it's been an absolute
pleasure having you on the program wish
you all the very best with the song and
look have a lovely Christmas when it
comes happy Christmas